welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and is Kang the Conqueror and
Ant-Man the WASP Quantum media cursed
with a sickness that affects how he
perceives time we're learning more and
more about this version of the king that
we're meeting in guanamania and how he
is different from he who remains in Loki
specifically his unique condition and
how his relationship with time is gonna
make this guy one of the most
interesting villains we've ever seen in
the MCU and also one of the most tragic
a few weeks ago at ccxp Marvel Studios
released a version of the quantum media
trailer with a new line from King
Scotland to a reality everything you're
fully gone to
yeah if you leave
at man afterward the casting group
guanamania did an interview in which
director Peyton Reed had an inscription
of this variant of Kang versus he
remains in Loki well I think that he who
remains in Loki is very different than
Tang the Conqueror in our movie
um they're variants but they are
extremely different people
uh Kang is someone who uh has dominion
over time but he's also very he
conserves his energy and he's a very
very scary character to deal with as
these two found out conserves his energy
an interesting way to describe Kang for
what reason would Kang need to
prioritize energy conservation why is he
short on it and or what is he saving it
up for this is clearly an important
theme for the character as a similar
comment was made about Kang by producer
Stephen Broussard in total film last
week Jonathan talked a lot about this
embodiment says Broussard he would use
the phrase no moves wasted that's how he
saw the embodiment of someone so
powerful so not only energy conservation
but literally the absolute of no moves
wasted this Kang is so obsessed with his
own timeline that he believes in no
errant Small Talk No Idol activity no
streaming shows they put on the
background while you do the Wordle
everything we hear him say and see him
Doom in quantumania is part of a
carefully calculated game plan something
rehearsed like in Nathan fielders the
rehearsal everything with a purpose and
everything with desired outcome
everything on script so that Kang can
stretch out his lifespan for as long as
possible because for him when he knows
his death every second is part of a
ticking clock countdown actually most
recently in an interview with
Entertainment Weekly director Peyton
Reed gave us the clearest teeth yet of
what exactly energy conservation and no
moves wasted actually mean he said in
the comics Kang has dominion over time
he's a time traveler his situation is a
little bit different in this movie which
I won't spoil for you but he's someone
who while we live very linear lives from
childhood to death Kang doesn't exist
that way it struck me as interesting to
take the tiniest Avengers in some
people's minds maybe the least powerful
Avengers and put them up against the
most powerful force in the Multiverse so
there it is this is such a big deal for
Kang in this movie that the director
doesn't want to spoil it for us but his
fear of wasting any energy comes from
the fact that Kang does not perceive
time linearly he doesn't see it from
birth to death and he's just somewhere
in the middle of those two points but
rather he is someone unstuck from time
and floating above it or rather just
living all of it constantly all at once
like Billy Pilgrim and Kurt vonnegut's
Slaughterhouse Five he sees time as a
flat circle not as a process of cause
and effect but really every instant of
his life happening at once because he
has lived all of these lives so many
times so why no moves wasted well he
doesn't waste any moves or words because
a nothing he says or does really matters
he's really confined by Destiny either
way but B to try to fight that Destiny
would be to contradict his own timeline
and create variances and branches for
himself that would lead to more chaos
for him and chaos is really his enemy
and ultimately see this particularly
timeline detached Kang is uniquely
immobilized so when Kang tells Ant-Man
I've seen How It Ends I think he's
talking about his own death as much as
Scott's death and when he tells Scott
you're out of your league he's not
dissing Scott for being a second tier
Avenger I think he's really saying you
only see time linearly cause and effect
you can't see where it's all going but I
can we are in two completely different
leagues of existence and a perception
and yeah this is a tremendous power for
Kang like Scott and the other Avengers
can't just beat him hand to hand they
have to somehow out think him and stir
up enough chaos to create a branched
timeline and then after beating them in
that Branch timeline they have to find a
way to patch that timeline after beating
them so that that Victorious timeline
doesn't get pruned or undone by a Kang
from another timeline yeah I know I set
timeline a lot in that sentence which is
why it's going to take Minds like that
of Doctor Strange or Vision or read
Richards to think all this through now
I'm on camera a lot so I have to see my
face a lot so you think I would have to
put a lot of effort in my skincare
routine but you know what I really don't
because I use geology geology is a 15
time award-winning personalized skincare
company recognized in hypebeast Bernie
Men's Health and Esquire and Aspen
grooming Awards with over 6 000 5 Star
reviews and they've recently expanded
the Opera products for pretty much
whatever you need all you got to do is
take this 30 second diagnostic quiz and
geology is going to figure out your
routine for you like if you need some
hair care well use geology's co-wash
it's a specially formulated cream
cleanser that removes buildup and
cleanses the hair without the big lather
or the harsh ingredients of typical
shampoo and for the rest of your shower
routine you can use their body washes
they're free of harsh ingredients they
smell great and are refillable and for
after the shower protect your skin from
environmental stressors with vitamin C
plus e for Relic serum to keep your skin
looking young and healthy and then a bit
of dermatologist tested aluminum free
deodorant that really smells great right
now for a limited time geologists
hooking our audience up with an
absolutely crazy offer use the code new
rockstars they will give you an
additional 70 off their award-winning
skincare trial set that discount applies
whether you're stocking up for yourself
or stuffing someone else's stocking
instead either way geology has you
covered check out their awesome gift
sets featuring all of your favorite
geology products to get started just
click the link in the description take a
30 second diagnostic quiz and their team
of dermatologists will design a
personalized routine just for you that
ships directly to your door in the case
of quantumania I think this condition
may also be a weakness or a curse for
Kang if he truly believes and applies no
moves wasted that makes it really hard
for him to adjust and improvise for one
it's really just a tortuous way to live
you have to constantly be thinking about
every word every gesture every step
every pause like imagine the boredom of
that life would have no joy everything
would just be about following the script
and the flow chart at all costs actually
there could be a bit of irony in casting
Bill Murray in this movie is Imagine
Kang as Bill Murray and Groundhog Day a
guy who has lived a single day thousands
of times so much so that he gets a
superiority complex over it I'm a God
you're a God I'm a God I'm not the god I
don't think but Kang rather than living
a single day a thousand times Gang has
lived his entire life thousands of times
he has run every possible simulation
he's killed every avenger and like Bill
Murray and Groundhog Day that power is
also a curse but a curse of time so that
leads us to the question how does this
curse connect with Kang's current status
in the quantum realm in Ant-Man the west
quantumania and what does he want
Scotland to steal for him I think the
king we're looking at here in this movie
is in a holding pattern kind of Frozen
in Time stuck in the quantum realm
unable to actually apply any of his
timeline plans or his thinking to the
Multiverse Beyond he just has to sit
there in this kind of prison thinking it
all through imagine him like Hannibal
Lecter and Silence of the Lambs someone
who's just sitting in his cage thinking
conservative energy and waiting for the
right moment to strike and Escape I
think this Kang has been exiled in the
guano Realm by other rival Kings or by
he who remains himself or maybe he was
just passing through the quantum realm
and then Janet sabotaged him to trap him
there either way his Loop is frozen
which is a pretty horrifying thing to do
to someone who sees time like a video
game simulation that they played through
thousands of times to just hit pause and
leave them there suspended like that
it's kind of like those folks in the
Chris special a black mirror so I think
Kang obviously wants to escape the Guam
realm so that he can continue cycling
through his lifetimes maybe find one
where he ends up with ranslayer or
whatever his desired Destiny is and here
in this movie when Cassie sends a signal
to Quantum realm Kang finally finds a
Lifeline to escape so what do you think
will this Kang die in this movie and
then future kings we follow and like
Kang Dynasty could be different variants
with different outlooks or will this
Kang return to his timeline loops with a
Vengeance and become the Kang that all
other kings fear let me know your
thoughts in the comments below follow me
on Instagram and Twitter at avos follow
new rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye foreign
[Music]